how did you come back there is a vocal
warmup that a serious actress do that
involves you yeah I mean you know my
name does sound a bit like a fart in a
bath at the best of times you can get
your mouth around it not the fart in the
bath I've got even that sounds dodgy I'm
on the ground not chuckling I know
really yeah if you can say it without
tripping over quickly I suppose it is
kind of a vocal warmup yeah
because they do what is it Benedict
Cumberbatch Benedict Cumberbatch
Benedict Cumberbatch read it I think
that's just that there's no isn't there
a better to convert something about a
luggage rack
there is no I've not forgotten there
I've got Benedict Cumberbatch broke a
delicate luggage rack that's it have I
just made that up no that's real yeah
yeah and Benedict Cumberbatch's or
something lumberjack or as a feminist
lumberjack yeah spending - Cumberbatch
is a feminist 11 language I can't see
let's chat you return as Doctor Strange
Avengers infinity war it's out next
Thursday now do you have any clue what
happens in this film yes I do can you
tell us anything about it no I can't
okay
you're Doctor Strange and you must be
helping the world in some way in some
way that is correct yes the world and
worlds beyond it potentially all we know
is that there's just shed loads of
superheroes in this thing yeah and no
one really knows that I've heard
everything from sort of 36 to 23 was the
most frequently quoted number but I
don't even think the Russo brothers it
director did know quite how many there
are in it I'm sure they do actually they
know everything but have you seen the
whole film you know no I really haven't
okay well let's watch a bit of it should
we watch a bit of it yes yes I'd love to
say this is you doing some talking we
some other Avengers and you're
discussing what you're up against it's
really bad okay that thing of putting on
you know the doctor strange outfit is it
like just putting on any costume or is
there a is there a thing I am a
superhero there is definitely a my
remember very clearly when I first put
on the whole thing including the cloak
is often miss called the Cape but it's a
cloak and it's really heavy it's like a
cloak but it first went on with the hair
and everything and I sort of looked in
the mirror I just went I just started
laughing like a twelve-year-old
and the costume designer Alex you've
seen it all just sort of folded her arms
I mean yeah seen that look before you're
right you having a superhero moment
unabashedly giggling at the face of a
superhero but you wear the outfit like
offset which seems a little tragic
contextualise I was filming in New York
and New York oversees the home of the
character so some of it had to take
place there and we were on his street
more on Bleecker Street and just around
the corner was a cafe and it was in New
York as I think in a lot of America you
the perhaps can just the paparazzi can
get in front of the camera they go hey
get out of my shot to the DOP who's
moving the camera around so it's it's
extraordinary and they were everywhere
this day they were just there were more
of them than they were crew so this is
getting a little rude because they can't
follow me into a cafe surely in the man
no they can't but your cafe I went yeah
it's a French word for a coffee house
I'm gonna go around the Coco I went into
sorry normal Americans too stupid I
didn't mean
listen
to say
[Applause]
fair enough
so I go to this cafe fully regale that I
don't really know if I could finish done
it and I walked him and it was very New
York that everyone sort of Turner what
and the coffee's were sort of half
between mouths and tables and people
stopped talking and then I just we got a
table I had blood and cuts on me and
encash human and the minute the wait
said yeah sure everyone just went anyway
I said st. Joseph's very New York
Knickerbocker strange
[Music]